Oh  today I have a very exciting  announcement I've chosen the winners who  will join me after play live challenge  sponsored by GE and SAS the winners are  as follows  in the beginner category Martin Rasmus  one Vanessa Sun and chest crave  in the intermediate Hannibal Lector  silent riddle and Joker  in the Advanced section hessed 1805  Rohan Naidu and Anthony Rizzo  in the expert category Aaron Arado the  the mm man and soul blazer I'll write  the usernames below and the winners will  receive an email with the details you  have three days to confirm your  attendance or I'll pick another winner  maybe see you at the play live challenge  and chess works event May 5th in New  York for the rest of you guys next  year's challenge will start as soon as I  reset the points